so I have to tell you the story where I
was hired to break into a major Bank
using social engineering techniques and
defeating their physical security to get
into their data center what I did is
when I first went into the lobby of the
skyscraper it was over 50 stories is I
found the number to the leasing office
of the building I called it I said I was
Jim Smith that we just had a fire in the
building and I wanted to take a look at
what office space they had available
immediately I'm now walking around with
the leasing agent she actually had an
access card daing from her belt with her
picture on it so I asked her I go can I
take a look at that she hands it to me
and then with my daily planner I put it
over it and what she didn't realize is
my daily planner that I was carrying was
a special daily planner with a little
bit of Technology inside that was used
to steal the card ID and the side ID so
I could clone her
card